CBS News has learned a letter from a
North Korean official to the US was a
key factor behind President Trump's
decision to cancel Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo s upcoming visit to North
Korea
the trip was planned to advance
denuclearization talks just months after
a historic summit between mr. Trump and
North Korean leader last week President
Trump blamed a lack of progress in the
nuclear talks when he canceled the trip
which Jang is at the White House we do
good morning good morning John president
Trump acknowledged for the first time
that little progress has been made after
declaring back in June there was no
longer a nuclear threat from North Korea
and UN Ambassador nikki Haley
acknowledged it's possible North Korea
may be having second thoughts about
giving up its nuclear weapons
yesterday defense secretary James
Madison ounce joint military exercises
with South Korea would resume after mr.
Trump earlier agreed to suspend those
exercises as long as the North was
negotiating in good faith sources tell
CBS News a setback unfolded after the
national security team met at the White
House here Friday and reviewed that
letter from North Korea which reportedly
said the north one of the u.s. to sign a
peace treaty to formally end the Korean
War Secretary Pompeo still remained
optimistic after that but it's unclear
when negotiations will resume Gayle all
right we show Jen reporting from the
White House thank you